Globally, the fashion industry produces 13 million tons of textile waste.
I capture it before it goes to the landfill and give it a new life.
I've spent so many years building my reputation as an environmental scientist.
It was hard for me to actually leave and start my own business.
Everyone thought I was a little crazy.
Maybe I had a lot of doubts in the beginning, but I knew I could make an impact.
Everything we do at Two Days Off is focused on sustainability and ethical practices.
We use fully compostable or 100% recycled paper packaging.
We only work with natural fibers.
We do very small batches,...
...and so this allows us to really manage our own waste...
...and be as lean and efficient as possible.
We're 100% carbon-neutral.
I'm Gina Stovall, a former geologist...
...and founder of sustainable clothing line Two Days Off.
Providing options in sustainable fashion is one of the many solutions we need...
...in order to solve climate change.